germanium is the first element in the
periodic table beginning at hydrogen
that's named after a country it's named
after Germany there are other elements
named after France and Poland and
America but we'll come to those later
one of the things about germanium and
what really makes it important in the
periodic table that this is one of the
elements from which was unknown
when Mendeleev constructed the periodic
table and he predicted its existence and
when it was found it had many of the
properties that he had predicted based
on the change in properties as you go
down and across the periodic table so
this is a small sample of germanium
named after Germany so you can see the
wonderful shiny surfaces germanium is
used quite widely as the so called
semiconducting material row if you look
at it in visible light it looks like a
metal germanium hmm
I have used germanium mirrors in some of
my experiments the lasers that I used
when I was younger had a germanium
mirror that let the light out at the
front of it and germanium is used quite
widely in electronics this is quite a
nice piece of germanium unfortunately I
broke it somewhat earlier in my career
but you can see very nicely how this
material looks like a piece of metal but
on the other hand if you shine infrared
light through it it's transparent so the
light will the infrared light will go
through but visible light doesn't